Олігархам - війна, інтереси громадян України - понад усе.
44-річний фронтмен рок-гурту "Океан Ельзи" Святослав Вакарчук
офіційно оголошує про створення власної політичної сили - партії "Голос".
З нею рок-музикант має намір не просто боротися за парламентські мандати
у наступній Верховній Раді.
Каже - хоче покінчити зі старою системою.
Ми, партія "Голос", ідемо в парламент знищити стару політику і творити політику нову.
Сьогодні, на жаль, Верховна Рада перетворилась на токсичне болото, яке засмоктує наше майбутнє.
Ми маємо це змінити.
З войовничою риторикою контрастує назва нової політичної сили - "Голос".
Схоже до Володимира Зеленського з його партією "Слуга народу",
"Голос" - пряма відсилка до пісні "Океана Ельзи" "Голос твій".
Також назва асоціюється з популярним конкурсом "Голос країни",
в якому Вакарчук неодноразово брав участь як тренер.
Програми партія поки що не має.
Втім, основні гасла, з якими "Голос" піде на вибори, від сьогодні не секрет.
Перше: інтереси громадян України - понад усе.
Друге: екзистенційний вибір України - Європа.
Третє: один закон для всіх. Четверте: вільна економіка без олігархів.
П’яте: влада, яка підзвітна громадянам України.
У команді Вакарчука - представники ліберальної та патріотичної спільноти,
є активісти і професійні антикорупціонери.
Серед них - екс-заступниця міністра економіки Юлія Клименко,
колишній директор Transparency International в Україні Ярослав Юрчишин,
відомий лікар-кардіолог Юрій Соколов,
колишня виконувачка обов'язків голови Одеської ОДА активістка Соломія Бобровська.
Несподіванкою став - "кіборг" та колишній боєць "Правого сектора" Андрій Шараскін,
відомий під позивним "Богема".
Вакарчук підкреслює, що робить ставку на нові обличчя - і загалом на молодь.
Я бачу тут молодих людей -
якщо чесно, в мене таке бажання - приєднайтесь до нас на сцені, якщо можна.
Я вас дуже прошу.
Хто може. Тому що це для вас, тому що це ви - символ Нової політики.
Проте сам музикант у політиці людина не зовсім нова.
В 2007 його навіть обрали до Верховної Ради від блоку "Наша Україна - Народна самооборона".
Втім, надовго фронтмен "Океана Ельзи" в парламенті не затримався.
Вже за рік Вакарчук добровільно склав депутатський мандат.
Після кількарічної паузи у політиці музикант активно підтримав Євромайдан.
За рік до виборів президента ім'я Вакарчука почало фігурувати у соцопитуваннях.
В електоральних рейтингах він певний час з‘являвся у першій п‘ятірці.
Попри те, що намір іти у президенти Вакарчук ніколи відкрито не декларував,
інтригу тримав до останнього.
Лише наприкінці січня офіційно заявив, що не братиме участі у президентських перегонах.
Декого з виборців така нерішучість розчарувала.
Проте ставлення до лідера "Океана Ельзи" загалом залишається позитивним.
Мені дуже подобається його творчість.
Що стосується політики - я думаю, що він просто патріот і думатиме про майбутнє країни.
Все впирається не в одну людину.
Якщо у них нормальна команда, якщо вони зберуть компетентних експертів,
які будуть працювати заради суспільства, то не проблема.
І вони тільки доносять думку.
Вакарчук, знаєте - ми ховаємось, а тоді ми виходимо. Як це зрозуміти? Скажіть будь-ласка.
Чого він не створив до виборів? Не вийшов на вибори? Як я можу цю людину зрозуміти?
Я думаю, що сам він не змінить, а з командою змінити може.
Чи зможе проект Вакарчука подолати 5-відсотковий бар’єр і потрапити до Верховної Ради?
Професор Києво-Могилянської академії, політолог Олексій Гарань вважає, що шанс у музиканта є.
А от чи вдасться Вакарчуку заручитися підтримкою інших політичних сил
та, найголовніше, об’єднати навколо себе країну - невідомо.
Багато що буде залежати від того, наскільки дійсно
вдасться Вакарчуку об'єднати навколо інші політичні сили.
Зокрема, це "Сила людей", "Демократичний альянс", інші ліберальні реформатори.
Коли Вакарчук давав концерти в Краматорську, туди приїжджали люди з окупованої території.
Він безумовно популярний як митець, але питання в тому,
наскільки це йому вдасться конвертувати в політичну підтримку.
Хоча я думаю, що об'єктивно його підтримка на сході і на півдні буде набагато меншою.
Втім, допомогти музиканту потрапити у парламент може майже абсолютна впізнаваність.
До того ж, окремо турбуватися про зустрічі з виборцями зірці не доведеться.
Адже як і шоу-мен Володимир Зеленський,
співак Святослав Вакарчук не планує відмовлятися від гастрольної діяльності.
Радше навпаки - лише до кінця травня "Океан Ельзи" дасть аж сім концертів.